why is it that people are holding
billionaires and successful people in
contempt at this moment they were Farhad
and the New York Times wrote this
ridiculous story about like we got a ban
billionaires I said I think about that I
was like wow isn't the whole entire
American dream predicated on there is no
cap to the success and isn't that what
makes us punch above our weight on the
global stage with only 330 million
people we're the dominant force even as
effed-up as Trump and everything is
right now and why is this happening
right now that everybody doesn't believe
in the American dream when the America
Marika's never had better employment
never had better productivity and the
standard of living is better for
everybody objectively
it's very weird to me it is a weird
dynamic so I I'm not sure how popular
our dynamic is versus like the people
have uh sort of an amplified microphone
tend to just proportionally share it so
I you know I think the American Dream
iam is still very aspirational for most
Americans I think that billionaires are
people and successful people in any
field are people we should emulate so my
belief in life is that if you want to be
more like a successful person you should
copy their traits and so if you want to
be a successful company you copied the
traits of a successful company has not
failed companies and if you want to
succeed in life you copy the traits back
to the days of Ben Franklin I mean like
Ben Franklin was like you get up early
you know you know like this stuff I
think also there's not a lot of Secrets
meaning like the keys to success aren't
secret just they're painful these - did
you have deferred gratification versus
immediate gratification so let me give
you a mundane example to start let's say
someone wanted to be for whatever set of
reasons a cover model for men's health
Conor with the right diet in the right
program in the right sleep most people
can achieve that it may take years of
training but the gratification comes out
for the years and the sacrifice comes
upfront same thing these days if you
wanted as you know we're both getting
older if you wanted to live five or ten
years longer there's a pretty reasonably
proven methodology for doing that which
is intermittent fasting severe caloric
restriction there's a lot of evidence
that that would extend your lifespan
forever but for five to ten years yeah
and you'll have a higher quality of life
higher quality life while your octave
like more quality years actually now
that said you have to restrict your
calories to 1200 calories and that's you
do that for years to get the benefit
right so I think most of life is can you
trade gratification long-term
gratification for a short-term sacrifice
and can you compress the feedback loop
and that's a product feature level is
just compress the feedback loop allows
more people to stay on the program and
not churn and you know go back to rest
their behavior but so I think like there
is a formula for most success but it
entails trading off short term and long
term gratification and you just have to
decide where on that dollar you want to
be